hello everybody I was gone that's the
most beautiful venue ever but probably
every speaker will tell that
watch your back brows are you being
observed let me quickly introduce myself
I'm Stefan sometimes I look like that
who has been at CSS comp yesterday yeah
this is an initiative that is called one
zjs so if you want to join us feel free
it's a lot of fun it's a very fluffy so
definitely really cool thing I'm a
front-end developer from Berlin
I'm occasionally teaching CSS and node
and I'm organizing the web performance
meetup in Berlin and my main focus these
days is open source performance where
performance and accessibility and I work
for a company that is called contentful
so we are a content management system in
the cloud this means that if you need a
CMS you can simply register give your
editors or non-technical people a web
interface and you as a developer then
only have to work with a with an API and
this is what you do anyways and with
content all we always say editors get a
CMS and we as developers don't actually
have to work with one which is really
really nice and last fact about myself
is I'm really excited about conferences
because you can learn so much stuff and
you can meet a lot of new people you can
have an excellent time you can make new
friends and these conferences helped me
to stay up-to-date because the web
platform today involves really really
fast and we are finally yearly egg must
releases new API browser api's are
coming out every day and we finally have
evergreen browsers right I'm really
happy about that
and staying up to date is kind of part
of our job and I personally have a hate
love relationship with that because
every day
we're dealing with this a new tool every
week but then the same time browser
api's adapt to common use cases right
let's think of jQuery and the dollar
selector today we've got document query
selector all and the browser api's are
slowly moving from a pool model where we
have to ask for information to push
model and what I want to show you today
is what that actually means but first I
think we should celebrate
because we've got a lot of cool new
stuff today and we're here and I believe
we will have two excellent days so what
I did is I took the J's computer pest
website this is how it looks like this
is the schedule looks good to me
but I think we can bring a little bit
more celebration in there so I spice it
up a little bit with a fancy lazy
loading effect in case you don't know
that one that's the Twitter heart
animation and I stole it from a nap
tutor who does crazy stuff in CSS and
this is done with one element so how
would you usually achieve this kind of
effect but first you have to figure out
if something is visible in the viewport
right so how do you do that
well I'd Google huh and then you sorry
and then you end up at Stack Overflow
who's guilty of copying this snippet
come on probably more people here and
then there's this piece of logic in
there which I I'm always too lazy to
think about that but this one got shot
with this though this is calling element
get bounding client rect and this
function on and anuman at Dom element
can trigger the browser to
asynchronously Nino to synchronously
calculate style and layout this happens
when something changed like adding in
class or something and this is a an
expensive operation
when you use this you should always
batch all the reads and then write stuff
but this is actually not cool because
well we have to pull for information
right we have to ask s Blissett li if
you understand shion's are good to use
performance wise Paul Irish is
maintaining this document here and when
you're doing these kind of things having
a look there it's definitely a big help
so what is next then well we define a
scroll handler right which fires 1,000
times when you scroll through a page and
there's also something wrong with that
because scroll or scroll handlers are
really expensive operation by default
and when we want to build great you eyes
that stick under our fingers when we
play around with our phones we always
have to aim for 60 frames per second
dividing one second by 60 means that we
have 16 millisecond but this is actually
not true because the browser has to do
some other same things then just dealing
with our JavaScript so in real time we
have around 10 milliseconds to avoid
janky scrolling this means that we want
to do as less as possible in a scroll
handler so what I did next is well I had
to my developer tools of choice and I
monitored the whole thing right these
are the chrome dev tools and first thing
I did is I throttled the CPU because
this device here and we heard that
yesterday already is not your average
user not everybody has this kind of
device and also not everybody has a
latest or recent phone and then I
checked the framerate of my cool lazy
loading effect and well it was not that
good right
and when we look a little bit deeper we
see that element get found inclined rect
takes big part of that and in this
example it took actually 12 milliseconds
which means that we already hit the
budget
and this is firing on every scroll frame
right this is really expensive so let me
show you one solution to this problem
the intersection observer the
intersection observer is a method to s
on personnel s synchronously query the
position of an element with respect to
other elements or the global viewport
this means with this we don't have to do
costly dumb and Styler queries and we
don't have to pause for information
using something like this helps us to
reduce CPU GPU and energy costs to
figure out if something is visible so
how does that work
here you see an intersection observer
implementation first you have to define
a threshold and in this case I'm going
with one point zero which means that I
want to get notified when an element is
completely visible then you have to
initialize a new intersection observer
and this is then called with several
intersection entries and these then have
a intersecting property and then I'm
adding a class that is called
party-party
and then I'm I'm observing the given
element because well my job is done here
and then I can just grab all the
elements and can tell the observer hey
can you please watch out here cool so in
with an implementation like that we see
that a now there is no get bound
inclined direct anymore and this is not
called onscroll and when we check the
framerate we see that at least for
figuring out if something is visible we
end up at 60 frames per second I think
this is really really cool so we're
building these kind of things I always
what I always try to do is take a moment
and measure it measured using the dev
tools of your choice use web page test
or lighthouse and maybe try it on a real
device which is not a six month old
MacBook Pro so what options do we have
for an intersection observer where we
can define a different route element we
can tell the intersection observer how
this is
and then we can define a threshold with
which is a single value or several
values and this is actually really
really cool because when you define
several values so in this example zero
and one I get notified when something
enters the viewport I get notified when
it's completely visible I get notified
when it starts leaving and when it's
gone and this is only a few lines of
JavaScript so let's have a look how this
entry looks like that that I get when
I'm notified that something becomes
visible so here we see the viewport and
here we see what happens when the
element enters the viewport so the entry
then has an is intersecting property
which is true in this case and an
intersection ratio which is something
around zero here why something because
the intersection observer works a sync
so the browser figures out when it has
time to figure out if something is
visible so what happens when it leaves
the viewport again we've got it
intersecting faults and then we've got
the intersection ratio of zero which
makes sense because there's no value
below zero right there was one thing
though that surprised me so let's go
with a value that is bigger than zero so
when we have an in ratio or a threshold
of 0.5 so something is entering the
viewport so we can have is intersecting
true and an intersection ratio again
something around 0.5 but when it's now
leaving the viewport roof cut is
intersecting so true this surprised me
initially because I was expecting it to
be false but it's intersecting tells you
if it's still in the viewport right and
when we go with the threshold of 0.5
this actually makes sense
and the ratio then is something around
0.5 and with the intersection observer
then we can build really nice interfaces
like something like that make stuff
appear dissipate peer when something
else changed in in the cutout of the
viewport and this is 10 lines of
JavaScript without googling I think this
is real
really cool and you can also use it for
figuring out if something is visible in
responsive web design so there are a lot
of use cases for for the intersection
observer
so how's their support today after the
section observer well it's not too bad I
would say but there was one culture
though when I started playing around
with this I discovered that they have
been incompatibilities between spec and
vendors and people got together and were
like okay we have to figure that out
because some yeah let's figure that out
but these are resolved since October 17
with the release of edge 16 so it's now
ready to go the only thing I would want
to tell you is when you use this without
a polyfill or something just watch out
and read maybe the issues and see if
there are issues or if you run into
these but how's the polyfill is this
poly fillable at all
it is and the polyfill also takes care
of this incompatibilities so this is
usable in production today so we
celebrated every talk here now I think
we can do more so let's celebrate the
whole schedule ready
if you get in case you don't know that
there's a third-party library that is
called cornified so I highly recommend
it so not got the problem the
intersection observer code was wrapped
in and immediately invoked function
expression so if no idea when something
changed or there are no callbacks no
events or something how could I now
figure out that my party party class was
added
well let's need another observer here
the a beautician observer provides
developers with a way to react to
changes in the Dom so how does that work
so here we see a basic implementation
and what I do is I grab the whole
schedule then I grab all the speaker's
then I define a config object which that
the which defines that the mutation
observers should watch out for
attributes and the whole subtree then I
initialize a new mutation observer and
then I get notified when there was a a
in na a net will change and then I'm
just checking if the element now
includes the class party party and then
I'm counting up and if this is done I'm
calling Korn if I edge and then well I'm
just telling the mutation observer all
right please check out or watch out for
or observe this element what options do
we have for mutation observer we can
define if we want to observe children
attributes whole sub trees and they are
way way way more options to define so
you can check out the spec or the mdn
entry for that how is the supporter for
the mutation observer pretty green you
might not meet this observer very often
but if so this is extremely helpful and
I use cornified here now and I'm also
I'm kind of a web performance person and
when you do something like that what I
want to tell you also is but let's
always watch out for performance right
and measuring performance can be done in
two ways
there is synthetic monitoring this
basically means that you send a robot
your sites gather some metrics and see
how you're doing that way on there's
also real user monitoring which means
that you implement some JavaScript and
you get the metrics right off out of the
browser's or of your visitors or users
for synthetic monitoring in case you
don't know it really handy tool is
called webpagetest
and what you can do there is you can
enter a website can define a connection
speed a location and then you get get
metrics afterwards if you wonder how
people make these kind of comparison
videos compare videos of two websites to
see what is loading when this is all
done with web page tests and this also
then gives you turned on and on tips and
tricks and a lot of useful stuff so if
you haven't used that yet give it a try
it's a really really powerful tool but
this is only one moment in time if you
look for constant or continuous and
performance measurements
tools like speed curve or calibre can
help you out there but I want to
actually talk about our real user
metrics and what we have there today is
the navigation timing API the resource
timing API and the user timing API so
let's have a quick look at what we get
out of these api's so the navigation
timing API is available via our window
dot performance stop timing and this is
an interface for a web application to
access the complete timing information
for the navigation of the document so
what do we get here well there's a lot
of stuff included this can be really
useful information if you measure web
performance there are stuff like how
long did it
TNS take how long did TCP take when did
Dom content loaded all these kind of
things are accessible via the navigation
timing API and then there's also the
resource timing API which is an
interface for web applications to access
the complete timing information for
resources in a dark
and you got more or less similar data
there a few entries are missing but
let's think of style sheets right style
sheets are render blocking resources
maybe you want to know when a style
sheet is hanging around or not loading
for 3 seconds because this is directly
impacting user experience and then
there's also the user timing API which
is an interface to create application
specific time stamps and you can measure
for example navigations in a single page
application something like that so let's
measure how long my Corning fication
took so here we see what happens when
all talks have been seen and I can now
set marks so I'm setting a mark before
and right after and then I'm defining a
measure which is the combination of both
marks how can I access this information
then how long it took well--there's
window dot performance get entries by
type mark and you see when it happened
there and by using get entries pad type
measure you see how long it took and you
see in this example was 6 milliseconds
which kind of fits into my budgets so
real user metrics right today exists we
can set mark measures so we've got marks
measures and navigation resources and
these are accessible via get entries get
entries by type and get entries by name
and that's pretty cool but this is not
what we want because using this we have
to pull for information we have to
detect when there are new metrics we
have to duplicate logic to figure out
what is new so let me tell you the third
one here the performance observer so
this is how it works so you have to
initialize a new performance observer
and then you can define what you want to
watch out for right in this case it's
type measure and then you get notified
and this is really cool because this way
measurements are pushed toward
me so I and I also had a look at the
stack man and it was like what was
written in there all right developers
today are encouraged to use the
performance observer all right I can
deal with that
but then there was also an interesting
sentence which was like further new
performance AP isometrics may only be
available through the performance
observer interface what new metrics are
we talking about here so there is for
example the paint timing API and this
API gives us information for example
when the first paint which means any
painted pixel or when the first
contentful paint happened which means
that any text image non white canvas or
SVG is rendered and this is shipping in
chrome for example since chrome 60 and
we're currently on chrome 61 this is
also available using get entries by type
and then there's also the long task API
which tells us when JavaScript
operations took longer than 50
milliseconds and with these kind of
things I've kept the metrics right at my
fingertips right so this is for example
my personal website and what you see
there is that I have a local storage
flag and with this this I get the
information how long something took
right on my face and I'm also relying on
the content API here so I also see how
long the API calls take but let's have a
look at another example here so this is
the Lando and what's the most important
thing here well I would say it's the
image right it's been 50% of the screen
so how hard can it be to measure when
this thing is rendered well today we
have to do this we have to define the
image with an onload handler this clears
navigation timing API marks then inside
the new mark and then we've got an
inline script afterwards so what this
basically does is whatever happens last
is the right
but this is not good experience at least
in my mind so there are also new specs
in the making for example like hero
element timing this is currently really
only in spec writing and discussing how
we could implement that but with
something like that we can get
information when something crucial is
rendered or laid out for example Twitter
is constantly monitoring how long it
takes until the first tweet is loading
and this is really valuable information
so let's see where this goes and just
for the sake of completeness
there's also server timing which rates
which the server can set via an header a
header and then this values can are
easily accessible via the performance
observer this only works in Canary
though today if you're interested in
more metrics regarding rep performance
there's this excellent talk that is
called leveraging the metrics that most
affect user experience I'm highly
recommended so what's the support for
the performance observer today I just
covered last week actually that Safari
joined the party which was surprising
though so it's not that bad is this poly
fillable well if browser vendors at some
point decide that they only want to push
metrics through the performance observer
the gern is more or less over but so far
the metrics are also available via get
entries by type so you can do a feature
detection check and then you are ready
to go so what we have now is a lazy
loading effect we've got unicorns and
unicorns are pretty gate great but
what's better than unicorns once this
again anyone what was that I didn't
understand it all right I'll give you a
hint and now did I did a glitter but all
right so I'm from Berlin I'm mostly into
indie music but I also like electronic
music and a good over near sunshine good
news
take dancing just forgetting the day
it's perfect to me so what I implemented
next was confetti and to do that I have
to cheat a little bit but I think that's
alright let's assume there's a slide up
and down thing in the website this makes
me really happy so how could we now
figure out if something changed its size
any guesses well there's also the resize
observer so how does that work so we
have to initialize a new resize observer
which then gets called with several
entries and then we're just telling hey
alright can you please watch out for
these elements cool I want to do
something I want to draw confetti then
you might ask yourself though okay a fan
but when is this firing the resize
observer fires when elements gets
inserted and removed from Dom when they
get set to display:none they are not
triggering on CSS transforms though and
with this information further I have to
tell you my implementation was broken so
triggers on on load that's not so cool
it's drawing and closing I mean confetti
is great but it's not really accurate
here and it's also triggering on on
horizontal resizing but I think it was
OK at that point right so one where
could we use the resize observer well
for drag and drop interfaces this can
become really handy this is six lines of
JavaScript and I can maybe a just scroll
positioning or something like that
and we are all waiting for element
queries right maybe they will be there
at some point the JavaScript
implementations are polyfill for this
are also considering using the resize
observer and to figure out if something
changed its size so all the support of
the resize observer today
we're entering cutting edge here I would
say is this poly fillable and usable in
production I would say so so they are
polyfills for the Wizards observer out
there and these use mutation observers
and they aren't they're not covering
everything so you might want to consider
if you want to really want to use that
today but we're still not really happy
so let's face the resize problem here
and let's take a step back
and let's see what we're actually
dealing with so here we've got an
element and this is a simplified version
for one element so what are we dealing
with we're dealing with this initial
call we're dealing with several opening
calls and we're dealing with several
closing calls and what we actually want
to do is we want to get rid of the first
one and of the closing ones so how could
we do this well here we have to call
back that is triggered on resize so well
we could soar boolean and toggle that
and how could we figure out if it's
getting bigger and smaller well we could
store the last run and then compare but
this code for me is not really readable
and it's also hard to maintain and it
has side effects outside of the event
handler and if you have several entries
that gets more more complicated so let's
enter the final topic observables just
because the name is fitting observables
are a collection that arrives over time
and currently they're only in spec but
they have already a widespread usage
thanks to our X and libraries like that
and they're definitely a talk on its own
so again observables a collection that
arrives over time so let's have a look
at an observable implementation so here
you see a function that is called get
observable with three values it's
initializing in Europe so
observable then it's calling next and
pushing values into this collection and
then it's completing at some point then
we're defining handlers for given events
of this collection and then we just
subscribe to that and then we get next 1
2 3 and yeah we're done when I saw this
for the first time I was like what's the
deal here
let's just shifting around callbacks now
but now we're dealing with the
collection which means that we have
stuff available that like maps will the
reduce and this makes it possible to
write rate cleaner code so this was the
initial implementation and let's change
that to use for example something like
Rx and new observable comes rx create
here and what I now have is a collection
of events over time and this gives me
collection superpowers so let's have a
look at the timeline again so this is
what we're dealing with and I'm calling
get resize string here which gives me
this collection that arrives over time
how can I get rid of the first one well
skip it
cool how can I figure out if it's how
the last run was well there's a function
for that pairwise cool how can I not
drop the closing ones filtering maybe
and how can I get rid of the previous
ones now map it back and then call the
stuff that I want to do this is pure
functional code without side effects
that's easy to read maintainable and
testable I really really like that so
with that my implementation was bug free
so what would so what we talked about
was the intersection observer to figure
out if something enters the viewport the
mutation observer to figure out if
something changed in the Dom the
performance observer to not ask for
matrix but rather get notified the
resize observer to figure out if
something changes in size and
observables which are a completely
different way of thinking and it takes a
while to get it I'm still freaking
freaking things out with observables and
I'm in the web development industry for
seven years now and oh well so much has
changed and web dot web development is
still fun it's probably we're a big love
in my life today but yeah we all have to
to admit and probably all know that so
much will still change and even if it's
exhausting I really really love that and
yeah we're all here in this really
beautiful when the venue and we have
really good time so let's all celebrate
I ready
[Music]
you
[Applause]